we are increasingly unable to hold two
truths at one time yes there are bad
police and there are good police there
is systemic racism and there are people
fighting against it there are some good
things in critical race theory and there
might be some things that you disagree
that doesn't mean you throw the whole
thing out 100 you know what i mean they
have to have just one thing it has to be
perfect and that's unrealistic
[Music]
you know for me a football coach was
always about inciting violence revving
up passion like conductors of
testosterone like all this like toxic
[ __ ] that like had nothing to do
with strength or being strong natalie
did not have to become more masculine to
be a football coach and i think that's
beautiful she had to just be exactly who
she was she's got this like this
unbelievable like quiet steady unbending
conviction there's a clarity and a piece
of mind there that i think just makes
her real as [ __ ] oh well look i have to
i get in trouble because i never do like
a a proper introduction but i i want
some but look you're gonna you're gonna
uh see very quickly i'm not walter
cronkite i sure as [ __ ] marv albert
i'm biting anybody but but um when i
look at you in your career
i had a diversity and inclusion
community
at one of the most uh prestigious i
guess that's the worst
private schools in the country um you're
a science teacher and administrator in
the dc public school system for what
like 10 years
i taught for 11. 11 years
head football coach of uh calvin
coolidge high school
which at the time made you
uh the only female varsity football
coach in the country at the time uh
professional uh women's professional
football player for the dc divas for six
seasons yeah you uh were the title nine
administrator for dc sports
you got a
full ride to uh virginia to run track
you were all acc
at
uh uva
um
look i think what we try to do with this
show
you know when i looked at that i mean i
know who you are and i
you know we've known each other our
whole lives
um i i don't know i was really just like
staggered by your accomplishments i was
talking to my dad about it this morning
and i think just like in a world right
now that is so concerned with with
optics
and with self-promotion
you know when i look not only what you
have done but how you have done it and i
and i feel like i have some real insight
to how you have done it you're one of
those people who have really walked the
walk not just talk that [ __ ] and that's
kind of like what this show is is really
about and and um i'm trying to think of
my first memories of you like i remember
you as the girl
well i remember you as the girl that
nick had the crush on because nick would
always talk about that that's what i
remember from like way back in the day
but what are what are like some old sid
well memories you guys were like the
jocks right you were the [ __ ] like
popular dudes on campus all the girls
loved gareth's eyes it's funny that he
said something with carrots eyes i
remember all the girls talking about
like
and you know you played football did you
play basketball no no no i played
baseball you play baseball and then nick
played basketball football baseball
and
y'all were like the guy i was kind of
tomboyish so like i really
i really loved like playing football
with everybody you know playing
basketball over here all day
um
that i needed that part
of my childhood to kind of get where
i think where i am now
but i was also very shy i said well like
i didn't
you know i was super super super shy i
mean i will say like when i first heard
that you were like coaching varsity
football i was like dad like now you
know what i mean because i do remember
you as like i mean i i don't really look
at it i just remember like soft-spoken
you know um
always kind always not confident like
it's so weird now you know people oh my
god you're so badass like how do you
like confidence that i'm like i'm not i
was not
like you gotta fake it till you make it
wow um
and that really was and where did that
come did that come like play did playing
football is that what playing helped um
playing football definitely helped with
teaching
um
and then
but you know it's different when the
world is like looking i mean you know i
wanted to blend into the floor paint
sometimes like because it wasn't about
that for you it was about the players it
was about the worst yeah and it was
during that time where i had no time to
think about what the world thought of me
you know what i mean and it's not until
now reflecting this far out
you know seeing what they've become
um still being in touch with them and
and having them be a really major part
of my life
um that i'm recognizing
oh okay through the coaching thing you
know my dad had already died
and
that was craziness and i could call your
dad and he would answer in the middle of
a meeting
and be like
someone just asked about my life right i
don't know what that is you know and
like
he coached me through that
in terms of the attention and and just
knowing like if if [ __ ] goes down
like i could call mr bernthal
and he'll pick up and i think that's
something you know like i i think you
know i saw that so much with my circle
of friends guys who were in trouble with
the law if you were like you could
always kind of and you know we had this
you know not when we were living here
but even in the old like we had this
like open door open heart policy that i
think we all kind of grew up with that
if you were part of the family you were
part of the family i mean even like we
got we got robbed like six times my dad
refused to lock the doors and and i was
like i mean one time a dude came in
right while i was sleeping on the kid
and i was i never really understood that
and my dad was like well somebody really
needs this [ __ ] that bad they say and
you know
you know i'm not like that like you
coming to my house i'm gonna shoot the
[ __ ] out of you know what i mean like
i'm not you know but like he he had that
attitude this and and i think it led to
this kind of you know they were foster
parents i mean um
just the other day while i was here i
was walking on the billy goat trail and
this little girl i walked by this girl
and i was like trying to keep my head
down because i'm trying to go on my run
and she was like john bertha i was like
hey hey how you doing you know and she
was like your mom was my foster mom and
it was like this little girl kissing me
she was like yeah they they saved me and
my my brother's like you know so you
know and i sent that picture to my mom
and it made her life and like you know
you
you know bringing people in your home
and and and being there sort of for life
i know that you've you've done that with
your students
you know and and you continue to do that
who was your role model to to do that
where did you learn that um i think i
learned it from my dad
and uh you know my father he had that
physical therapy practice in northeast
and after he died you know i realized
his finances were a mess and then but
reflecting he let people pay him in
chickens for physical you know what i
mean like they literally could come with
whatever they had and he would treat
them
and
he
you know going to a school like sidwell
and the privilege that we all had you
know
obviously i did come from northeast to
cross the park but my father let me know
like yeah you might not live in potomac
but you're still privileged as [ __ ]
and you need to
both remember where you come from and
understand that everybody is a human
being and you treat people as such and
just watching him care for people
for whoever it was it didn't matter who
it was he just cared for people
and then having that reinforced with
just like you said our relationship with
sidwell like you know with with you guys
and it's just like
okay well kid needs a ride home duh yeah
kid needs some money
no
don't think twice about it and just
my goal especially with them
during that time where it was so crazy
with the media attention
i was like this is their high school
experience
yes this is a story with your football
players yeah like but this is their high
school experience that they're going to
remember for their whole life that was
always just putting them first in
everything that i did and every decision
that i made and then just understanding
the reality of my situation
i was young had no kids like all i have
is a dog like i have the time i have the
space i you know in some cases i had the
money to do whatever they needed so why
not what am i going to say no
you know i don't know about you but i i
think that like
growing up in dc when when we did i
always just found there was
this unbelievable
kind of in your face
contradiction
slash hypocrisy because you had this
city center that was always
you know so clean and so monitored and
watched and um
the real city was something really
different and then i really felt that
you know going to
the school that we went to and these
claims of of diversity
and inclusion how do you look at that um
i look at it as this hypocrisy and
contradiction and everything and you
know my boss now had a school brian he
gave us his book um about managing
polarities
and there's not
for many things for many complex
problems there's not a one answer one
solution it's a polarity to manage and
sometimes it swings this way and you've
gotta correct to bring it the other way
and then sometimes it swings all over
here and you've gotta constantly correct
and i think life is like that life is
complex
and you know the socio-economic dynamic
the racial dynamic they're complex
things they're complex and unique in dc
and
sidwell is a is
it's a great place
it's an exclusive place um
but i will say like the steps that i see
the school taking is a totally different
school than when we were there
right and that makes me feel good
they completely trust in me and my
leadership and my vision
um they've thrown money at it
which you know that lets you know that
they're serious
and
but it'll always be a contradiction like
the kids now you know how we were we we
you know raged against everything and
said what kind of letter and one thing
baratunde said when he talked to the
kids was like
we were [ __ ] on this school and the
school gave us a platform with which to
do so you know
and the kids now are like oh it's a
contradiction between quakerism and you
know all this elitism and it's like
you're gonna see that wherever he goes
we are like people who have money um
are going to do the best for their
children
and they're not going to just put their
children in a bad situation just because
they're going to use that money to to
provide for their kids but it gets
complicated when people start saying
what's good for your children what's bad
for you you know what i mean and when
someone says hey you need to be around
this kid that you can learn so much from
this kid because he grew up so
differently than you and he's seen so
many different things i'm interested in
what you're talking about about the
polarities because that's also just
something that's one of the reasons why
we're doing this show i think the folks
with platforms right now and what you're
hearing is you're just hearing a whole
bunch of yet whining and screaming and
yelling by one side and then a bunch of
wanted screaming i think one thing they
taught us well it said well is the
discourse right we sat around and we
discussed like there was not much lesson
plan
you know we sat in english class in a
circle and went at it yeah yeah um and
just the
that
skill of questioning things and not
accepting things without
you know well why is it this way and i
took that into teaching and you know i
was in science so my goal was that the
kids like i want you to learn how to
figure [ __ ] out yeah yeah i want you to
learn how to question things how you do
that right
um just give them a problem and say go
and then they hated it too who was the
answer i don't know figure it out you
know and then they they get used to that
and they get used to that vulnerability
of not knowing humans don't like to not
know
um
and i think that's where these these
factions that we see now because
everybody is pitching their solution to
it all or their reason
and nobody is comfortable in the
complicated mess
and the complicated message where it
happens that's where you have to live
having a discussion with someone who
disagrees with you and really listening
to their point you probably won't agree
that's fine you might not come out
agreeing but you're sitting in that mess
you gotta be hungry for that you gotta
be you gotta be hungry
that person you disagree with exactly
and then you know people don't do that
enough and i think but what's it what's
the enemy of that like what's the enemy
of that is it is it is it emotion
because that's what i think you know
like and there's obviously there's all
this other stuff i want to talk to you
about fear there's and there's like you
canceled culture and like you don't want
to say something to get get offended
it's fear and comfort
i think fear and comfort are the enemy
of
the sweet spot in the complicated mess
because we don't want to be in the mess
you know and that's why like the other
thing i like to read about is the brain
like your brain makes up [ __ ] in your
field of vision like you're not seeing
it as it is like you have blind spots
and your brain fills that in our brains
don't want to not know
and so now in a world where you can find
whatever you want to find
um on youtube and go down whatever
rabbit hole pleases you and you don't
have to you never have to be confronted
with someone who disagrees with you
other than through you know on the tv
screen and you can vilify them and you
can you know twitter at them and all of
all of those things and you never have
to really be confronted with any mess
and
so people are comfortable
and and i think you know
living in the mess takes some
intentionality and it's hard and that's
what you know
that's where a lot of my work is at
sidwell there's a view that has been
um nurtured in our brains unconsciously
sometimes for decades because they are
seen the only black boys you see on tv
are doing drugs or in a gang or wherever
um and so
you look at them differently and that's
that systemic racism piece right like
the systemic barriers that that people
of color have had in this country um
are to blame not the people
the people themselves in a bad situation
it's not because they're lazy it's not
because you know they're not smart it's
because there's a barrier there and
there's generational barriers that that
nobody can overcome you need people with
different perspectives because you have
kids we have 54 students of color now
that said well friends
so you have kids walking through that
door
that come from different backgrounds
have different identities i consider
myself a liberal and progressive person
the thing that i rub up against is what
i call or what i look at as like
this
racist classist element of the liberal
progressives that i see all the time and
that i i really found kind of growing up
with and like look i mean i can tell you
that
one of the people
that i've learned the most from
in this world this man named alfred
brown from shreveport louisiana who i
will put up there wisdom-wise i'll put
him up there with anyone he got a life
in prison sentence the fbi agent that
put him away said had he been born in
any other community this dude would have
been bill gates and i i like my life is
richer i'm smarter i'm better because i
got to know him and i think for me you
know and that's that systemic barrier
had he been born in any other zip code
straight up straight up that being said
he wasn't right and and what i found
that at some point in my childhood there
was an active
effort and i and i credit mr williams as
much as mr williams scared the [ __ ] out
of me and all the times i went to his
office and you know he was a serious
dude man and i i was not like the you
know he he meant trouble to me but you
know i really believe that what mr
williams knew is that not only could he
do amazing thing for these young men but
he was serving our entire community by
not just saying hey we need more
black students we need more asian
students we need more it wasn't about
that it was it was diversity in every
way and like how the how the whole is
served that way and and also what he did
for you john you were scared of him
he was a smart
strong
person
and he was a black man straight up
straight up and you got to know that
black men can be that at a very young
age for sure and that that is also why
diversity and inclusion is so important
because if you don't see people in those
roles
then it becomes an anonym an anomaly for
people it becomes like oh and you don't
know what to do with that but you got
that early you got to see this smart ass
black man straight up scare the [ __ ] out
of you and you had respect for him 100
right i i yes i think that's right i
guess and i don't really know i i guess
like my question about it though is like
where does it work where does it not
work
i think it works what i try to do with
the hiring thing is that just that like
you're
we need multiple perspectives to see the
problem if you look at the problem from
one direction look at the elephant off
from the back you're just going to see a
elephant's ass you're never going to see
the trunk
people's perspectives are shaped by
their experiences their experiences are
shaped by their multiple and
intersecting identities so as a black
woman i'm gonna have a different
perspective than quinn as a black man or
you as a white man and in order to solve
this problem we need to look at it from
all the different angles it doesn't mean
i'm any less qualified i'm just as
qualified 100 but you know and that's
where our
our mind shift has to happen is like
you're looking for a qualified person
just the way you look for somebody that
has a degree in this particular you know
journalism or whatever because you're
hiring them for a magazine job
you need somebody with this particular
perspective
you know that's that's a hiring criteria
and and so look so that's that part and
where i think it i mean i think it works
in that
again the data shows you solve
complex problems faster scientific
discoveries are made much quicker by
diverse teams than they are by by
homogeneous teams and then
i think where you have to be careful
though
is
is about the mess we were talking about
earlier people get so like the whole
liberal white thing and that's hard to
deal with because then you've got to
this person who really thinks they're
doing the right thing
i have to explain why you're not doing
that thing
and then there's also like
explain that racism that's hidden
underneath there even toward me yeah i'm
a white man in hollywood right now
believe me like every time i get into a
room with just white men they want to
tell me how there's no rules for white
men and it's hard out there for i'm like
yo [ __ ] like you are out of your
[ __ ] mind it's the same with the me
too [ __ ] you know like there was a time
when the me too was coming on like i'd
be with a group of actors the second we
were alone as all men they'd be like yo
man i hope i don't get caught up i'm
like y'all are janky you say young black
men were always portrayed as like gang
members or stuff like that let me tell
you something man there's a lot of gang
members like gang members in this
country for some reason
a lot of these guys played the cards
that they dealt a lot of these guys grew
up in areas of complete power vacuums
where it was unsafe and these guys
banded together and provided safety for
their community and i think a lot of
these young men the ingenuity the
organization the creativity the the
loyalty the care that it takes to sort
of run a neighborhood whether legal or
illegal in these abstract [ __ ]
meetings nobody's telling that no one's
get that's not getting celebrated at all
it's not getting no no there's nobody
illuminating that and and to me you know
when you talk about media you know we
talk about motorcycle gangs that you the
the italian mafia man honor among
thieves like these dudes like we love
that [ __ ] you're glorified like [ __ ]
cowboys uh you know the you know peaky
blinders but you talk about black street
gangs and they're savages they're
they're they're reckless they're all
over the place and for me it's like
you know
this isn't just
this is not just about race that's so
old john what's so old that that
parrot or that that discrepancy of you
know
quinn and i were just talking about
james baldwin the other day or yesterday
and like he used to say it like when
white people
revolt and and fight the power it's a
revolution when black people do it
they're savages or whatever i'm saying
the quote wrong but like that is an old
thing and that is from and what i've
learned the history that we didn't learn
is you know that pervasive bit of
slavery and why
race was created to maintain the
institution of slavery slavery was bad
in order to
make it but it's lucrative
in order to
make it worth or make it justifiable
these people are savages so they deserve
to be enslaved and so you create those
stories and those stories are old the
story of the black savage the story of
the dangerous black man this is all
those are old stories and being
perpetuated right those are all those
are ingrained those are those are
internalized by even black people
all of this is mess and it's not
necessarily to be cleaned up we have to
live in this mess in order to have a
diverse society all these problems are
the more diverse you have the more
clashes within the diverse groups you're
going to have of course it's really
simple for me and like the way that i'm
raising my kids
any force
that pull that that pushes people apart
that plays against the intrinsic human
need to come together with people
understand people compromise with people
that to me is just like the the enemy
one of my main reasons i really wanted
to do
this podcast it really started with like
one specific thing and that was you know
like you know after george floyd um you
know during the protests and during the
movement you know i like so many people
was
you know
obviously just completely horrified and
terrified and outraged by
you know what i saw and you know i was
at a time when you know i had already
lost my cousin to covid dougie's father
had already died from covert was a very
real thing for me and my family and i
really wanted to be out on that the
streets you know a part of that movement
was very important to me
at the same time i was looking on the tv
and i was seeing police officers um
having bottles and other things thrown
at them and people screaming at them
people cursing at them and
a lot of my really good friends people i
i know are in law enforcement and it's a
community that i i have a real
relationship with and i'm looking at
each of those people and i'm saying
you know they're somebody's kid they
have kids they're somebody's brother or
sister and you know i i had a real
problem with that and i said you know
look if i i want to go out and i want to
be a part of this protest but i also
want to show my support to these guys
doing this and what what i've really
found with policing in america right now
um i've just spent like the last month
with the you know people in the
baltimore police
and nobody is uh
more disgusted and and and outraged i
think with the the corruption and the
brutality and the savagery of of bad
police than than good police like there
is there's an oath that a peacemaker
makes to the community that they live in
which is that they'll put their life on
the line for the good of the community
my friend jerry bellasteros career lapd
in newton down south central he he was
you know he's been there 20 years they
used to give him coffee and invite him
into the restaurants and now they're
spitting in it and tell him he's not
welcome anymore and um who is that
hurting that's hurting the people in his
community it's hurting everybody and i
think you raise a really good point um
and i do too also have
um people i love in law enforcement and
i think
and it's funny i did a teacher class
it's well now um called the dmv and it's
basically just complicating everything
for the kids um and and it was so fun
because they the dmv like like the dmv
or the the department of motivation
maryland virginia so robbie gross and i
taught it and one of we did
i had my friend from this leadership
program come and he
did a lesson for them on affordable
housing and we touched on how affordable
housing is is key for recidivism to keep
recidivism down
and they got to talk to one of the
residents at this housing facility
and he
they asked one of the kids asked him so
what do you think about defund the
police and he was like i think it's
idiotic
you know this is a black man has been
put away for 20 years and now he's back
and the kids were totally floored they
didn't understand that i was like you
have to understand like like this is
real life for them sure like
his his neighborhood would be dangerous
without the police and i think all of
this
it's the polarity thing
we are increasingly unable to hold two
truths in this
at one time
yes there are bad police and there are
good police there is systemic racism and
there are people fighting against it
there are some good things in critical
race theory and there might be some
things that you disagree that doesn't
mean you throw the whole thing out 100
you know what i mean and people are
increasingly finding it difficult
to take one piece of something and one
piece of something else and one piece of
something else and hold that in their
hand they have to have just one thing it
has to be perfect and that's unrealistic
that's not life of course but you can't
vilify an entire race of people a
professional people like that i mean i
think so i guess so is that your biggest
frustration that things have to either
be all good or all bad yeah yeah yeah
and i'm really trying to get people to
sit in the mess where two things that
seem totally different might actually be
true what is your sword to not even
fight your way out of the mess but fight
your way through the mess like it's to
me my hunch is it's the sensitivity
and
the grandstanding and the opt like
throwing up optics on this way so i'm
like on both sides you can't tell me
anything because i like that i just i'm
pretty sure is the enemy it is and a
very wise woman named loretta ross she's
a professor at smith college and um she
wrote this article in new york times
called uh calling in a calling out
culture and she
graciously talked to me for an hour like
i just emailed her out blue and um well
no cat dawson put me in touch with her
but
anyway she's like calling out is the
enemy that's not how you get anything
done straight up you know what i mean
like you have to somebody does something
wrong
you call them in and tell them hey
this was really insensitive and this is
why and i really you know i respect you
and i appreciate you and i don't think
that you did that on purpose but this is
true you know right and you hurt me and
like people can't do that they have to
do it behind a
facebook or behind their tweet or
whatever and it's like calling people
out and getting them fired and that
doesn't do anything but make you an
enemy sure or make you afraid to afraid
to say how you feel or have the
conversation in the first place that
person goes and like you know what i
can't say anything i don't want to say
anything so they don't engage i can't
work with you if you don't engage that's
right so like i told you know the people
that said well like
my goal is to broaden the scope of ejc
because we have the gung-ho equity
people and then we have the people that
aren't so sure and people are so quick
oh they're racist they're part of the
resistance like stop
okay
if they're part of the resistance they
still work at this school and they still
teach the children and so we have to
bring them in somehow and you can't
bring them in by wiping them off but
generalizations and racism is racism as
general is it it's the same [ __ ] so if
you say these people are all this where
these people are it's like you can't do
that [ __ ] you just can't do that [ __ ]
yeah and you have to
we have to get more comfortable having a
conversation with someone and finding
one thing that we connect on and then
you go and you recoup because some of
those conversations are hard they take a
lot of energy yeah
and you know you okay we've agreed on
this we disagree on this fine uh you
know i still respect you as a person
and be able to move on and it's just
it's gotten so far apart
where people just don't have the skills
to do that and that's part of what we
have to focus on is not necessarily
yes the ideology but
the skills to have a conversation the
skills to think critically about
something the skills to be able to hold
two things in the same space that might
contradict each other
and the hunger the the hunger to be
challenged the hunger to be like you
know i can learn from you we are so
different yeah just explain to me first
of all like what led you to football and
what do you love about the game football
is the best sport ever um
it's the greatest team sport i will
argue anybody down how how's that um
you cannot win the game just with one
player you know what i'm saying and
everybody has to pitch it if the o-line
doesn't block for the quarterback the
korak ain't doing [ __ ] that's right you
know if if the if the linebackers don't
you know fill in those like
nobody can do anything without the other
person um
and just like for me personally
football
and contact sports i think for women are
essential how so um
you know as girls we don't we're not
socialized to rough and tumble and roll
around with people um like boys are but
the act of hitting another person
gives you a confidence over your body
your physical body that i don't think
you get in other ways and that's
important you know all the statistics
show even just not just contact sports
or sports in general um girls that play
sports are less likely to get uh
sexually assaulted you know all of those
things
um
but it gives you a power over your body
that's like unmatched and i don't
because i remember my first hit right
claudia hogan yeah what was that that
was in pro football yeah and explain
that oh my god so we had a blocking
drill and like you know
i was fast like claudia is you know as
we always claudia's raised by wolves and
she you know we just had to block and
she hit me and i was like
i was like okay
i think i know what i have to do now
yeah yeah yeah and what and what is it
what did you have to do you have to
throw yourself at another person
straight up and go for blood yeah and
then it's so [ __ ] addictive yeah yeah
yeah yeah it just feels so good tell me
about nat tell me about you as a player
my strength is i like to hit
um but i didn't really get to play
defense i got to play kickoff team okay
which i loved even though we would beat
everybody like 75 to nothing and nobody
likes a blowout except me because i
always got to go down and hit the person
yeah yeah yeah um
but i you know
they put me at receiver i was fast i had
to learn the skill i'm you know i can
run in a straight line
the other things take a little bit of
practice and so at first i could catch
the ball but i couldn't stay on my feet
so every time i caught the ball will
fall
and then i got the hang of it and i was
still the shy natalie like and then one
day in eerie pennsylvania we were
playing the team and i think it was
brian mitchell he was like our honorary
coach for that year or something
and he was like put her on kickoff team
wow
brian mitchell legend yeah yeah yeah and
he
because they make her the gunner and i
went down and i hit the girl like she
just caught the ball and
yeah and then she started to cry damn
and i was like i'm so sorry
and then it was just so wonderful and
every time we scored i was like yes we
scored we're on kickoff you know yeah
everybody go hit somebody but it was it
was just it was everything i needed to
pull me out of that
shy unconfident person that sid well had
kind of created you know and um
yeah it was just it was
learning how to be confident in your
person but like what made you like what
was that decision in the first place why
were you like yo i'm going to try i'm
going to try out for a professional
football team because i loved football i
would watch it all the time i know i
can't tell you why what i don't remember
when i started liking football i would
just like watching it how did being a
player influence you as a coach and vice
versa like how did it inform your your
coaching
um
i mean
with the skills that i picked up i tried
to put on to you know the kids i was
coaching and then the other thing um is
that i you know i knew one position
really when they hired me
and they were like but you can organize
so i i was the organizer and i had to
hire people who knew more um and then i
started to learn um
but just and i was a teacher yeah yeah i
know how to teach kids i know how to
teach people things and so football is
just another thing but i i i just i
guess like you know the thing is and
like obviously like you've talked about
like there's such a fascination because
it's a woman in football and football is
what it is and that now that's like just
that that that's just starting to kind
of like break through in a more major
way and you're a pioneer there but i i
guess like being a woman
how did that help if it did and how and
how did it make it harder
um
i think it helped hopefully and you can
ask quinn this for his opinion
um
they respected me
you know and and they knew that i loved
them and so
and the kids are always easy right it's
the adults that that give you most
problems
um because kids just want to do well and
so if they see that you're you know
you're about them and you're not
bullshitting because they have a very
accurate [ __ ] meter then they're
fine
um the adults have all the you know
preconceived everything and and whatnot
um
and so i had more problems with adults
than ever had
at problems that you would have had
being a head football coach period or
because you were a woman because i was a
woman and what were those um just you
know the offhand com like the all those
this stupid ass comments um
people riding the wave at first and then
after that like it gets all like okay
like
you know
you're not
i guess maybe it's a resentment i don't
i don't i don't really know where it
came from um
and not being treated the same
there wasn't there wasn't anything like
i don't even remember but it's the
comments and the way people viewed you
and
the way they listen to you or not
or like oh that's nice yeah you're
saying that but and
and then if you actually knew what
you're talking about oh and then what i
found
was that many football coaches don't
actually know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about you know like football is
not rocket science and people think just
because you have a penis like you
automatically know all things about
football like
it is not rocket science anybody can
learn football and then
teach it to someone yeah yeah um and
that was the part that was always like
funny to me that people were oh my god
how do you do this
like i can read yeah yeah yeah yeah sure
being able to communicate effectively
within an all-male environment
was going to be important it's not about
me it's about them if i'm going to step
into this i need to make sure that i do
everything that i can to make sure that
they have a positive experience and what
did you want for them more than anything
else as their football coach i wanted
football to not be it for them
i didn't want football to be their last
resort
i wanted um which is the stereotype you
know and i didn't want it to be like a
way out or yeah their way out i wanted
them to know that they were just as
wonderful and fine and capable
regardless of football so how do you how
do you do that make them go to class
and you know stay on them about their
academics you had mandates on your team
right like what were your mandates they
had to go to study hall they had to get
a certain gpa they had to fill out their
little card every day the teacher signed
the card and if they skip study all they
can't come to practice you know or they
skipped my class i remember their
coaches shook their head at me
um they were like you sat your starting
quarterback jamie and i was like yeah
he's getting my class
and play
um
but you know like because at the end of
the day this [ __ ] isn't important high
school football and most of them aren't
going to play you know and then we had
one kid
stixx made it to
the practice squad of the texans and i
took a picture of the screen when he was
on there in preseason
and he's not an nfl anymore you know
what i mean right right but
they've graduated and they are thinking
about other careers and
you know that that is important for me
for them to have
options for them to have experiences
if they stayed with the team they all
went through the college process and
were admitted into a college or
university that's amazing so they
applied and were admitted their you know
financial aid and all the things that
were our different monsters and some
started a little later than others but
they all tried it and did it yeah you
know what i mean and or some
post-secondary like we have a few
firefighters
um you're still a part of
many of these
these kids like
me and you know i'm closer to some than
others but like if they call
i'm gonna do what i can
there was also part of your career where
you were um title ix administrator and
and where were you successful where
weren't you what were your frustrations
there what were the things that what are
the things that you're proud of with
that um i'm proud of
we looked at a lot of data we were able
to get data from the school so i had to
dc has this law that you could collect
all this data in athletic programs
people kind of didn't think it was an
award i had to train coaches and
athletic directors about gender equity
so again mostly
male
clientele and having to
um appeal to them about something that
you know
a lot of people would rather not think
about and what was the status of like dc
public high school
women's sport like because you came from
a school where women's sports were i
mean it was i mean across the country
girls of color have met far fewer
opportunities to play sports than other
girls and that is primarily because they
don't get it early because early sports
are usually pay to play and so folks
that don't have the means don't get to
play and then by the time they're in
high school
girls you know if they haven't had the
experience they're not really going to
try it in those adolescent years where
they're trying to fit in and they're
trying to make boys you know that so the
time to get it is when they're young and
really
bringing awareness to that and giving as
many opportunities as we could in high
school um and a lot of it is you know
some of its funding but some of it was
honestly the kids didn't want to play
you know you would start a volleyball
program it'd be hard to get eight girls
really working with the non-profits in
the area like dc youth rugby winners
lacrosse dc scores you know that bring
kids into those sports at a young age
and feel that that that spark in them to
to play um because you see just how
beneficial sports are like for women 94
of women in the c-suite have played a
sport
so
high-powered women majority of them have
played a sport and then
54 of them have played a collegiate
sport wow of what women wear in this
c-suite like so ceos cfo like what do
you call it c-suite yeah i don't even
know what that was i was like the
c-suite i don't know what the c-suite is
yeah i didn't know the c-suite was well
sorry okay are you good but yeah i mean
and see i you know what i mean that's
you got to listen everyone you know what
i'm saying
so not okay okay that makes sense you
know what i mean and and
that's huge for women gender equity in
corporate america like sports is huge
and so if you have such a disparity in
girls of color starting at a young age
you're going to see that disparity up
there too and and that's why it's so
important what is your take on this big
debate going around now about um
transgender
transgender uh biologically born men
playing in women's sports i mean i think
so it's different in high school right
than it is in professional i'm gonna
deal with high school and middle school
let the kids play what they want and
people act like
you know
all these boys are going to just say
they're transgender so that they can
play women's sport that's not true no
boy a teenage boy can come out and say
i'm transgender just because
you know what i mean like with the the
stigma and nobody's gonna do that um and
the in the the the amount of times that
this happens is very very
statistically small
um so there's that like i believe when
they're that age let them do what they
want um
and it's not that big of an even in high
school yeah i mean it's not that many of
them and they talk about oh well the
boys
you have just as much variability within
the genders
sometimes as you do across the gender
you have a little frail little boy
straight up and you're a grown-ass man
and you i mean you coach high school
football there there are men and boys on
the same
they're two different species exactly
that is fair but you know but we look at
this as
as such a an injustice and and i just
don't think it's that serious for the
high schoolers and then when you get to
professional find to do to make a
testosterone level for which you know
you can perform at this or the other and
and we've also got to look at
our binary culture as it is you know we
live in a binary gendered culture a
western dominant culture there are many
indigenous cultures that are not binary
and they have third genders and they
it's a thing and they call it's you know
they have words for that
um
so this is a very western construct
um
and it's it's a small percentage you
know and and and i think that being
transgender is real you know
feeling like you should be something
else
is real and who are we to tell somebody
that that's not true and that they
should you know just be banned from
doing this thing and you can do it you
can look at it case by case right like
we had a biological boy
who was
identified as non-binary
played football
also played volleyball
oh
there's no volleyball for boys in the
east coast you know um
so it's non-binary the child can play
what they want the person who brought it
didn't want to file i was like fine file
a complaint but you know put your name
on it they didn't want to do that
um
and
right
and um and i was like if it's such a big
deal fun
well other other
kids might do that no they won't teenage
kids are not gonna put themselves
through
scrutin un you know necessary scrutiny
just to play on a on a girl's team who's
gonna do that i feel you on that and and
i think maybe what this question is
about is about just the state of youth
sports in general and that it's like
from the you know my son bill was
walking around with [ __ ] in his diaper
three years ago and now he's playing
travel baseball with his name on the
back playing like 600 games a year and
people are taking it so seriously like
they're going to probably it's a big ass
problem and i think these things are
really related and i agree with that and
if you can fix that maybe you can fix
the other that being said
as you know
for so many of these people and for so
many of these folks whether we agree
with it or not sports is
a ticket to i mean sports is a ticket to
the university level sports is a ticket
out or even if you're just
you know not even a ticket out but it's
it's you know
attaining a college scholarship is a
serious thing
and there are just fundamental
differences between men and women and if
you're losing and and and i hear you i
don't know i don't know that i can get
down with your notion that it's just
such a small number because i don't even
mean anything that's just where we're at
now that's just like you know i mean
like anything like that you i think you
have to look at as like are we saying
this is okay because why can't you play
boys soccer and identify as a woman
but like you're playing with the gender
that you were born into because that's
your physical makeup and that's
it's equity you know what i mean but but
right i'm i'm just one like what would
be you know like what is the you can
still be whoever you are i think we have
to adapt i think this is one of the
things that it's it's ingrained in our
particular culture and we're gonna have
to adapt in both directions
um
i think that you know we're gonna have
to think outside of the box i don't
think the solution is in the structure
that we have right now and that's part
of that mess right we have to look at me
as a woman because a transgender person
they are
the the opposite sex right
if you tell me as a woman to go play
boys soccer
i don't want to do that i'm not a boy
right and so
that we are going to have to really look
at where we can meet somewhere out of
where we are right now i don't know the
answer and i agree like if if
populations increase and in terms of um
transgender folks in
playing sports
i mean we'll have to look at it but i
don't think
just forcing people to be into something
that they really are not
is right look i think there's no
question a lot of this is just the the
fundamentalism and the the the insanity
that goes around you sports and how tied
into
you know economics that is right now and
i i'm with you on that and they are
talking about
you know
certain parameters to playing like if
you are a um a transgender girl which
means a biological boy
and who who
identifies as female
um there are some parameters where you
have to start hormone therapy before you
can play in a certain sport right so
they're gonna they're starting to think
outside of the box with those sort of
parameters professionally testing and
testosterone because you also have
intersex people that olympian straight
up intersex straight up so she has bulk
yes but she identifies more as women and
then you know what is that level of
testosterone that would
put somebody in here and maybe it is lev
just measuring having categories based
on testosterone level and not on
what your identified gender is like
you know but but i would also say
there's there might be
the the part of the issue might be also
like what you just said i identify as a
woman i don't want to play boys soccer
but
you know
well why not like i also like why not i
mean it's like i'm doing this thing for
my mom
prosthetics and orthotics it's like
giving a black person a white leg and
saying it's still a leg
like no it's but it's not me it doesn't
look like me it's why should i have to
conform to this because you don't have
something to so it's it's it's more
about
it's more about that person's identity
and that being recognized
rather than can they play on the boys
team sure
but do i want to if i'm a woman and i
you know forced to be honest boys and i
had to go in their locker room i was
like no i don't want to do that well why
would you have to go in their locker
room i mean you wouldn't you know what
i'm saying you won't have to but i
the notion of being transgender is more
about their
sense of identity that's deep in their
soul and not just a technicality that oh
you can just do this that's what not to
say that that couldn't happen but
that would be
from what i've learned um from
transgender folks that i know of it's
it's a matter of
just that being them i have a teammate
who who is now using male pronouns
right so he
um just a few years ago
was
identified as she but always felt like
you know this isn't right this is all
right and like he called me he's like
you know i'm gonna use he him and i was
like good for you
you know and he hasn't gone he's not
playing sports or anything but he hasn't
gone through any of the hormone therapy
or anything like that but that
he is so much more comfortable
now just as a person that's beautiful
right that's beautiful and like
it's hard it's hard and that's why we
need to have these conversations because
there's nothing that i think matters
more what a beautiful
you know time that we're on the cusp of
like getting to these places and and to
live in a country where that's possible
and like there's nothing i want more
than for your friend to to be who he is
you know um but i would never agree with
like and i think that if he wants to
continue to play on the divas he should
be able to and you know yeah it is it's
something that we need to think about
and talk about and have
parameters that make sense and that
honor people's humanity this is not just
a technicality for people this is their
humanity and whatever we do and however
we talk about it we need to honor that
um so i mean i don't have the answers
and when we get to do older and we deal
with money and we deal with you know
scholarships and things we need to put
some parameters in place and that's okay
yeah um
and we got to be able to have these
conversations
without everybody getting all twisted up
exactly like you can't just shut it down
like you know and cancel this person or
that person because they said this or
that like
that doesn't get us anywhere
it just gets two sides that don't agree
and then you don't have nobody has a
good experience yeah so yeah i
appreciate you homie i appreciate you
coming quinn come on in here man
what's going on man that much man thank
you yeah
yeah oh
you got that uh that lob so so uh quinn
man
uh how are you bro i'm good yeah i
appreciate you being here thank you for
having me yeah of course of course what
have you thought about that just this
conversation that we've had with matt so
far well um if we backtrack to the
beginning um everything that she's been
saying right now
it resonates with me you know because i
get to experience it firsthand
and um i just i'm just like you are
grateful for the way that you grew up
i'm grateful for this experience because
not a lot of people
get to i guess exit that environment and
come into a new
unusual environment that you know it's
beneficial for themselves
you know i can't complain and when did
you first meet uh what do you call her
by the way randolph you call her
randolph yeah you always call her
randolph not coach randolph not miss it
just randomly randolph yeah and where
did when did you first meet her she was
my ninth grade environmental science
teacher so i had to be about 15. what
did you think the first time you heard
that she was gonna be your football
coach um
a lot of people resented the idea but i
think
that history that we already had
established with her like she said
earlier
established that respect at the same
time in that trust did you know anything
about her as a football player like did
you think that
you didn't know she played didn't even
know she coached pride to us
and did you have uh
i mean did you feel like she had any
knowledge about the game of football i
didn't care about it because to be
honest with you um
i wasn't knowledgeable about football i
was acting off pure instincts and i just
was an athlete like i said so i just
went out and performed i left the whole
mental thing to them and you know
um so i i didn't look at it from that
perspective no no hesitation no
no everybody was down with it yeah they
had they had press conferences and
everything and you know we were right by
our side smiling and just you know
supporting her and what were those first
practices like uh
like what did you think of her as a
coach your first impressions intense
how so it's just good like it was she
fit in it it didn't seem like she had to
go through a period like a buffer period
you know to get used to it it was just
like natural for her and she wasn't
trying to prove her it wasn't yeah it
was just yeah she fit right in
everything went smooth uh-huh yeah from
my memory from your memory
and did you ever see her play football
never never so i met her when i was in
the ninth grade and i've never seen her
before in my life and uh how were you
guys
us with me you
how were you how was the team the team
in my opinion you know when we reflect
on it now and apparently we weren't that
good if we compare ourselves to people
outside of the dc area but
when i was in that bubble
there was no one that could touch us
they were good yeah you were real good
you guys went to the turkey bowl yeah
and uh you said in there that she was
just lucky that she got a whole bunch of
athletes yeah yeah really yeah yeah like
there's so many schools in the dc area
that just sucked yep and
to stumble upon and i won't say stumble
but you know i mean yeah
yeah it was all like on both sides of
the football you know we were deep you
know just talented so that first
two or three classes they had a lot of
athletes that were already there we
brought a few in but i wasn't big on
recruiting
um
but you know we just tried to steer them
as as best we could but they were good
and looking looking back on it what was
uh what what was nat's strengths as a
coach
what were her weaknesses consistency and
i and i would say her strengths
you know
they were off the football field you
know like what yeah like we realized
what was important because of her you
know academics like the football thing
you know like she said this may not be
your way out so you need to start
thinking about other things um you know
you are good right now but you know it
only goes so far
so i think her you know giving us that
different perspective
was extremely important i grew up in
foster care
and
every month i would have like a social
worker come to my house and just check
in
and
this is around the time where i had uh
graduated from high school went to
school on a football scholarship and
came back
and you know i just needed help i needed
support um and my social worker was
trying to relay that to my my guardian
so i invited randolph to one of my
meetings one time just for the heck of
it just so she can see like what it is
that i actually go through
and you know my my aunt she was just
going off like i'm not helping him my
guardian was i mean my social worker was
trying to get her to record like
understand like hey
you got to understand what you have here
in quentin like he's different than most
males around him he actually wants to do
something he actually wants to get out
but he needs help doing it you know um
and she stopped the whole meeting and
she looked at me she said you come to
live with me
simple as that and i pack my bags up and
you know moved in the basement wow and
how long that was 2014.
wow yeah
wow
and then i left for the military the
next year wow
what do you think changed while you were
living there
it provided it provided me with like the
the hope that i can you know
i can do more
because you know growing up in an
environment that you know i came from
i only see people that are like me i
only see people you know in society's
eyes that are failures so how can i
aspire you know or hope to be more than
what it is that i see on a daily basis
so when you know i went to her home and
i see how she lives she showed me the
other side she i met her friends i'm
like oh okay you know now this starts to
click
so i mean just perspective and just you
know a different lens like i spoke on
earlier he was the quiet one that you
didn't want to [ __ ] with
and a few people figured that out um
but and he you know he always said
people always think i'm mean because
kind of he just has his own you know the
face he puts on and and he's chilling
but
and he used to always come and check him
ran up did you eat
i'm like no i haven't eaten yet had no
money but right somewhere
chick-fil-a or whatever he had he would
give me some you know and just that that
this kid
would think of me
like that and like i would you know
coaching was hard for me i was very
depressed you know i went i'm you know
went to therapy antidepressants the
whole bit and
um because mostly because of the
unbelievable time commitment but i think
it was just a perfect storm you know my
father passing in the way that he did
and just you know everything and and
having to
all of your insecurities are put on
blast for the whole world so that was
kind of and and it was i was really
stressed out about making sure that this
was that i was making
a
a good experience for them like that was
that really weighed on me
um and there were some really dark times
and
the thought of him
is what got me through like i can't
check out here like
what's that going to say to him you know
and um reflecting back in terms of like
how did being a woman maybe help them i
think the respect thing like seeing just
like mr will you seeing a powerful black
man and mr williams them seeing a woman
to be respected
um
makes it normal for them to respect a
woman um and then like there were the
wonderful times like singing adele
someone like you in car and in the
office like we like they used to belt it
yeah and i'm i'm like oh my god only you
know like what have i done
but i mean those were the beautiful
times i mean they lit like they printed
out the words and everything
um
but
you know so yeah i think that
just being authentically you whatever
that might be is the lesson um
and that's how i you know people all the
time questioning me
how do you get them to respect you
like how do you get somebody to respect
you you know what i mean like what kind
of question is that or are you going to
tackle your players
would you ask tony dungy
like what coach tackles their players
why are you asking me that but it's the
same thing like even now talking about
how women in sports are treated by the
media and and how especially black women
the double standard like for serena
versus other tennis players and the
questions that they ask us i experienced
that firsthand i'm like you don't this
is a dumb [ __ ] question yeah are you
going to wear a skirt to the fit what
what yeah
so it's like that kind of stuff
but i mean they don't do that anymore
i mean
cali
jennifer and lo are exactly who they are
and they are nfl coaches that have been
in the playoffs
you know and so um
i'm just glad that that
we and got there we got there quick you
did
you got there quick straight up 10 years
yeah
yeah thank you thank you that was
awesome y'all this is fun yeah i really
appreciate you guys i don't know it's
gonna be all there yeah yeah
[Music]
that's what's up
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff it'd mean a lot to us
i hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself